[Music]
hey
[Music]
on and on and on
[Music]
baby let me introduce
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the giveaway i don't always
do giveaways but when i do clearly we
like to do it big
and i like to give you guys as many
chances to win as possible so that's
clearly what's happening here so we've
heard time and time again about these
these smartphone prices going up and
down but really we have these new these
thousand dollar flagship phones that we
didn't have before are they really
necessarily worth the thousand bucks to
your wallet
debatable but can't really argue with
free so here's how to enter because you
have a choice you have a choice between
iphone 10
and samsung galaxy note 8. it's the two
new main thousand dollar phones of this
year the android one and the ios one and
they're all skinned by dbrand and the
signature red and black so half of these
phones are skinned in matte black and
half of them are dbrand's new red dragon
skin so if you want to enter to win one
of the note 8's follow me mkbhd and
dbrand on twitter
that's it you're done you're entered but
if you want to enter to win one of the
iphone 10s follow me mkbhd and dbrand on
instagram that's where the iphones are
at done that's it i realize most people
are probably going to enter both that's
cool too that's allowed in the rules
this is also an international giveaway
so you can win from any country on earth
and it's cool and it's a true giveaway
so there's there's no import fees no
taxes no paying for shipping you just
win and get the phone so all the winners
of these will be announced on december
25th so christmas morning which is
pretty awesome and if you have any
questions about any of the details the
dates the rules stuff like that i'll
leave that below the like button if you
want to check it out but it's pretty
straightforward you've probably already
opened a new tab and entered already and
shout out to dbrand for making this
giveaway possible and getting these 50
000 phones on this table in front of me
and eventually into your hands
and uh that's pretty much it
50 phones all flagships many will enter
few will win
thanks for watching good luck
talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]